qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour toi
vendredi soir donc pas tu fais ton
spectacle
ben moi je fais mon spectacle je joue
assez long la salle est pleine et en
fait s'avère que j'ordonne il dit pas
tout puisque je le vannes pendant le
spectacle pendant 20 minutes avec son
copain donc tu savais que c'était mutu
ne savent pas du tout il s'est passé un
truc assez incroyable c'est que je
l'appelle chatons ce qu'ils sont de
jeunes et je dis ça va chatons et lui
dit qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie me
dit chômeurs et la salle dit non
dits les pas chômeur lui
et je joue mon spectacle on ne sait pas
pourquoi je me dis c'est quand même
bizarre à la fin du spectacle c'est une
tradition c'est que je serre la main au
public il me serre la main il m'attend
pour faire une photo ce qui est quand
même assez pervers parce que je connais
pas de journalistes puisque autour de
cet environnement qui font une photo
sans s'identifier avec le mec du sujet
et là il ya un mec du public qui me dit
lui il m'a posé des questions ils font
partie d'un site d'extrême droite à ce
moment là ils sont sortis dehors par mon
garde du corps mais c'est ce qui nous
leur dit excusez moi ce que vous êtes
des journalistes oui les gens
sortiraient 50 personnes dans la salle
c'est pour ça que je trouve que là c'est
ma parole contre la sienne c'est mieux
qu'ils et 50 témoins objectivement
l'humiliation dans laquelle ils seront
18 à 20 personnes voilà à 90 il ya
cinquante personnes puis les gens
commencent à partir et à la fin il ya
vingt personnes qui restent avec moi
mais en tout cas moi ce que je dis à
tous les journalistes qui ont fait un
travail remarquable sur ce boulot là ce
qui n'est pas le cas de jean marc
morandini de recevoir parce qu'en fait
il faut faire un travail journalistique
pour savoir ce que les témoins vue on
peut pas recevoir quelqu'un on peut pas
recevoir quelqu'un d'autre mais ma
parole aujourd'hui si toi tu me
demandait de venir seul et confronter
mes propos ça serait assez injuste pour
lui mais il ya des témoins il ya des
caméras de la version donne un signe non
mois après je lui dis quand je vais avec
une centaine de personnes je lui dis ce
que tu es
lundi nous sommes jordan livre noir dit
oui j je vous ai déjà dit je parle pas à
l'extrême droite benjamin castaldi l'a
dit un valérie je ne veux pas parler à
l'extrême droite et j'en croise de temps
en temps si valeur actuelle me dit bon
yassine belattar je peux venir vendredi
je peux avoir de place c'est mon libre
arbitre de dire oui ou non mais par
contre venir me contraindre et pardon un
peu d'humilité quelqu'un qui a même pas
une carte de presse à la limite c'est
pas grave y en a qui n'ont pas de cars 2
passe souvent bon boulot mais quelqu'un
qui est journaliste depuis deux semaines
deux mois qui ce combat comparé à élise
lucet c'est des gens on part sur un
principe de base qui est plutôt
inquiétant là j'appelle la police parce
que je lui dis tu n'as pas le droit de
me filmer sur scène et ça c'est normal
c'est juste nous et les gens en fait se
tourner vers lui en disant mais attendez
moi vous m'avez dit vous êtes comme brut
et cosmique qui sont plutôt des marques
disons le plutôt sympathique le mec qui
vient ils disent bonjour je m'appelle
livre noir comme il l'a dit j'aime bien
voilà je suis un peu d'extrême droite on
en est là quand même à faire dire à
quelqu'un ce que tu es d'extrême droite
oui non il est pas c'est pas des
communistes étant bien même si c'est un
comique c'est pas grave mais lui veut
même pas dire qu'il est d'extrême droite
et il a posé des questions à mon public
dans dans la queue en disant est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils les islamistes parce
que vous êtes au courant que c'est un
humoriste sulfureux et alors bizarrement
tu sais qu'il a interviewé que les
blancs
et en fait il a interviewé un noir qui
lui a dit on enlève ton truc parce que
je suis en train de vérifier je crois
c'est pas les bonnes questions
quand je vois ça moi une fois que j'ai
effacé mes images devant moi j'appelle
la police il est dans mon théâtre il m'a
filmée devant et la maaf mais yassine
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont
dire est ce que les propos que tu as
tenu est-ce que tu le dit ou pas des
trucs il m'a dit qu'il a dit qu'il avait
il avait un petit peu l'avait poussée
que tu l'avais un peu à nancy mais je ne
regarde je te raconte les choses là je
suis piégé excuse moi et viens tu veux
me piéger pour faire quoi et en plus
quand je suis ici accessoirement je te
le dis pourquoi tu viens dans mon
spectacle si déjà tu veux pas provoquer
par dont il ya que des professionnels
c'est pas grave si on est en désaccord
mais me piège pas j'ai pas envie de te
parler j'ai pas envie de parler à
l'extrême droite de ce pays c'est mon
choix personnel et là je réalise qu'il
s'agit du jordan dont tout le monde
parle dans le 93 depuis deux semaines
parce qu'il ya un gamin qui s'est fait
interviewer par le même la même chaîne
youtube qui se retrouvent à dire dans
une énergie oui je vais décapité zemmour
c'est inadmissible mais on sait bien que
n'importe quel mec aujourd'hui dans une
cité qui à un moment tu lui mets un
micro sous le nez il ya tu as de la
chance d'avant la mère de la nissim
c'est inadmissible nice mais moi je me
retrouve là tôt à défendre zemmour c'est
inadmissible mais il se garde bien de
leur dire attention les amis après je
vais vous faire un montage qui s'appelle
le grand remplacement avec un montage
qui fait et je ne sais pas qui la
soutiennent valeurs qui exacerber les
tensions déjà palpable dans notre pays
pour te finir l'histoire quand la police
arrive et je remercie la police du 18ème
et lui disent effacement des images
merci il efface est écrit cette phrase
que la police rendent je suis pris en
otage la police dit on se calme jeune
homme est là il dit cette phrase
incroyable il m'a lancé une fat man
alors des gens ont dit une fatwa
forte tout les fatma de ce pays je n'ai
pas envie de vous balancer et là ils
prient devant 50 personnes il essaye de
me faire une milla tu sais je vais dire
un truc qui m'a touché le lendemain qui
avait dans ma salle raquel garrido
alexis corbière oui mais elle a vu le
même spectacle je n'ai jamais traité
dans ma salle
natacha polony ou zineb el rhazoui de
[ __ ] tu connais mon humour vous avez
vu mon spectacle il ya bien un
journaliste dans ce pays qui aurait dit
le gars est fêlée deuxièmement je n'ai
jamais dit quand je rentre sur salle les
blancs lever la main sortait de la salle
non mais si tu veux aujourd'hui il faut
quand même préciser dans quel état
d'esprit on est ton lieu et le dernier
lui on peut le justifier un moment
l'extrême droite ces gens là sont
derrière eric zemmour je le dis à eric
zemmour pour moi il était candidat
jusqu'à ce qu'il aille sur l'un au
bataclan parce qu'il ya une estime qui
se crée entre nous on ne profane pas la
mémoire des morts pour faire une
candidature politique qu'est ce qui se
passe là derrière exe moses j'ai eu un
coup de mou depuis deux semaines dans
les sondages parce que les français
quand ils le voient parler écologie
économistes disent on va quand même
revenir à la raison qu'est ce que je
vais faire et bah tiens il ya des mecs
qui sont autour de lui qui se disent on
va aller fricoter ce que ce que disait
très bien thaler kelly la porte est
ouverte moi j'ai envie de dire à ce
garçon là mon ami un avocat j'ai un
avocat j'ai les caméras de sécurité j'ai
50 et moi que je ne connais pas qui sont
en train de témoigner dans la presse en
disant voilà ce qu'il a fait voilà ce
qu'il a dit et à la fin de la journée
moi je te le dit cyril je te le dis avec
beaucoup d'émotion si cet homme et moi
on était dans la même salle et s'il y
avait un cadavre la parole de cet homme
ressemblerait à celle des blancs
américains durant la ségrégation disait
c'est un noir faut le prendre et la
faune pendre médiatiquement est ce que
tu crois pas que moi je préfèrerais
venir et dire aux gens mon spectacle est
offert un tout le monde c'est l'un des
spectacles qui marche le mieux en france
les gens viennent pendant trois heures
rigole tu peux me dire tu me fait pas
rire mais me faites pas dire ce que j'ai
pas dit et ensuite je te le dis comme
squillaci mais il a il est journaliste
depuis deux mois venez on est des
professionnels des médias aujourd'hui ça
c'est des journalistes instagram il crée
des polémiques qui arrivent des bosses
il a voulu te plaisais donc toi mais
attend ses ingénieurs déjà quelques
jours pardon 2 - l'extrême droite je
parle pas avec eux tu sais pourquoi je
vais t'expliquer par une phrase très
simple il ya quelques années il mettait
en scène dans des trains pour les camps
c'est des gens qui s'attaque aux
homosexuels
c'est des gens samedi il ya eu la
manifestation nous tout ils attendaient
des féministes avec des barres à mine
c'est ça l'extrême droite c'est des gens
qui disent que les manouches y a rien à
en tirer
nous sommes un pays fait de minorités
qui veulent vivre en france sans qu'on
leur rappelle tout le temps qu'ils sont
différents ce garçon là est en train de
s'enfoncer publiquement dans un mensonge
moi la vérité je te le dis je suis
serein je suis serein n'a pas menacé du
tout menacé de quoi non mais ce qu'il a
dit qu'il avait poussé qui avait étalé
ses lui mettre une ligne droite mais il
ya 50 témoin je t'en supplie cyril moi
je vais lever la main sur un mètre
devant 50 témoins et lui met un coup de
poing voilà la grille est ouverte les
gens lui disent sauf si tu veux sortir
voilà et là je suis affecté et je le dis
devant vous ça m'affecte pas ce que
cyril ce n'est pas un combat que je vais
arrêter si je dois donner ma vie pour le
fait qu'on respecte les gens qui me
ressemblent ou les gens qui sont
différents de moi je donnerai ma [ __ ]
de vie je donnerai ma carrière je ne
suis pas pour que le front national de
vienne quelque chose de banal dans ce
pays il faut que tous les gens qui
regardent ton émission le comprennent
les rappeurs les humoristes les
footballeurs les gens qui ont de la
notoriété se disent que notre pays est
en train de s'afficher mondialement nous
sommes un pays qui mérite mieux que ces
débats de caniveau où des gens peuvent
te dire que parce que tu es arabe des
jihadistes parce que tu es 2 go tu es
islamo-gauchiste parce que tu es
homosexuel tu es un mec dangereux qu'est
ce que c'est que ces histoires
de débattre avec avec le jour bonne non
mais tu sais je dis oui vous m'avez
manqué ce que tu as des battures il
m'avait manqué tous battus ici ouais
pour une raison simple je ne suis pas
revenu parce que je pense que nous
sommes dans une cacophonie et je ne
parle je ne peux pas me permettre moi de
critiquer le système médiatique est de
venir essayer de te dire tu sais quoi tu
as mon rib fait - virement est là tous
les jours la dernière image qu'on a deux
mois sur cette émission faut dire la
vérité c'est un homme qui s'appelle eric
naulleau qui se lève pour une frappe et
il n'ya plus débat tu m'as tu m'as
envoyé un sms tu m'as dit cyril jeu on a
je vois là je sens qu'on n'a pas envie
que je sais pas on n'a pas envie que je
vienne dans l'émission je t'ai dit pas
du tout si tu es ce que tu m'as dit
enfin tu m'as dit voilà je sens que dans
l'émission le eric naulleau a dit une
phrase le lendemain on parle devant mes
collègues je vous remercie d'ailleurs
mais je n'ai pas eu l'impression d'être
un mauvais collègue je ne me suis je
vous dis tous bonjour on a des
désaccords tu sais quand quelqu'un te
dis sur un plateau télé comme eric
naulleau mais c'est pas grave ta phrase
tu élimines yassine belattar ne doit
plus venir dans cette émission c'est toi
qui produit c'est toi qui anime mois de
ma vie et je connais les gens autour de
cette table aucun d'entre vous n'aurez
pris le risque de dire lui faut pas
qu'ils reviennent donc aujourd'hui je
vais dire quelque chose moi ce pays
c'est le mien il appartient personnes à
l'exclusivité de ce pays ton grand père
ça peut être un mérovingiens le mien
s'appelle apsley belattar il a tabassé
des nazis pour que les juifs retrouve
une place dans l'histoire du monde faut
pas oublier d'où on vient quand certains
aujourd'hui se prennent pour le maire de
barcelone et deviennent soudainement
espagnol nous on est restés en france et
moi j'en ai marre j'en ai vraiment marre
quand ce week-end vendredi j'ai joué
trois heures j'ai rigolé j'invite
n'importe quelle personne de cette salle
à venir me voir si j'étais quelqu'un de
malsain et il sent les produits des
choses dans ma vie j'ai été le premier
humoriste cyril affaire le bataclan
françois hollande était dans ma salle je
suis le premier et maurice français y en
a pas d'autre et a mis le nom d'un
musulman sur la façade de cet immeuble
pourquoi pour montrer que les musulmans
étaient en désaccord
ce que des prêts dans tu prétendu
musulmans ont fait auparavant je suis
fier de ce que je suis je suis fier de
ce que je suis et ce que je vais le
répéter je suis un mec qui est né en
france qui est de confession musulmane
je suis bien dans les deux personne ne
dira le contraire